think the Privileges committee is pretty
damn it you know it's serious Boris
Johnson he's not only a law breaker but
a liar he's not fit for public office
and he's disgraced himself and continues
to act like a you know pound shot Trump
in the way in which he tries to
discredit anybody who criticizes his
actions when actually a decent public
servant would have done the honorable
thing would have had a little bit of
humility and would have apologized to
the British public for what they put
them through
he says he hasn't done anything wrong
that it's a witch hut that they've set
out to get him from the beginning
what do you make of that response I
think it's a load of rubbish and he
knows it and that's why he didn't
challenge you see that's why he's
resigned because he knows he wouldn't
win that by-election because he knows
the public could see through this act
this clown act that he puts on whereas
it's pretty obvious that that report is
very damning into what happened and he's
disgraced himself and he should
apologize to the British people I miss
you soon I shouldn't have propped him up
for as long as he has and the British
public shouldn't be paying for the law
breaker and the liar for his legal
defense when he hasn't got a defense
because he's banter rights on what he's
done they recommended a 90-day
suspension obviously that won't happen
because he's resigned but also stripping
him of his parliamentary pass so he
wouldn't potentially even be allowed
back in the Palace of Westminster is
that going a little bit far for somebody
who was prime minister no I don't
because somebody like him should never
have been prime minister because he's
shown that he can't uphold the standards
in public life look under prime minister
sir Boris Johnson we had the ministerial
code continually breached he did nothing
about that we had the scandal of PPE
contracts and cronyism we've seen him
trying to stuff the Lords with people
that aided in a better dim during that
period and he's undermined his office
and he's undermined the Office of Prime
Minister he's a disgrace prime minister
he shouldn't be anywhere near Parliament
he should apologize to the people for
what he's put them through people lost
their loved ones and wasn't able to see
people in their dying minutes while he
was getting drunk at number 10 having
parties knowing full well that that was
completely unacceptable he should have
admitted it he should have apologized
and instead he's blaming everybody else
which is a pattern of behavior from
Boris Johnson he needs to start to grow
up and accept responsibility for his
actions
he says that the Privileges committee
can't possibly know what was going on in
his head does he have a point with that
well the Privileges committee are not
trying to see what's going on in his
head they've gone off the evidence they
followed due diligent process and
they've come to a conclusion which is a
very damning conclusion the Privileges
committee are made up of members of
parliament from different political
parties including conservatives their
job is to find the truth and to put
forward the report which is what they've
done and to try and discredit them when
he's the discredited one is a
disgraceful pattern of behavior and it
cannot be allowed to stand not in the
heart of parliament not in our democracy
it's unacceptable and he needs to go now
and he needs to apologize
for what he's put the British public
through he won't though because Boris
Johnson never accepts responsibility for
the things that he does and it's about
time he does
the Privileges committee are talking
about contempt of parliament as well in
the way that he responded to the report
and the way that his supporters have
besmirched it and talking about taking
disciplinary action against some of them
would you agree with that I think he has
had contempt for the Parliamentary
process but I think the British public
can see right through that I think he
needs to reflect on what he's done he
needs to apologize to the British people
they put so much trust and faith and
confidence in him and he's let them down
he's let himself down and he's let the
public office down in the way in which
he's conducted himself and to me seems
like a toddler that's thrown his toys
out of the pram because he's been caught
and he doesn't like it Boris Johnson
thinks he's above the rules and always
has to but now he can see and I hope
that this process continues I hope we
get that vote on Monday and it goes
through because people need to have
faith in our democracy and faith in our
processes and this is the right thing to
do the privilege committee have done
their work without fear our favor
despite Boris Johnson now trying to cast
a doubt on that privileges committee
that that committee worked diligently
compiled their report came with the
findings and it's now time to accept
that report and move on Boris Johnson
says he's going to be back but do you
think this is the end of Boris Johnson's
political career I think the public can
see through Boris Johnson now sema's the
class clown that he is and want nothing
more to do with him I wish him a long
retirement
and finally this Tory infighting
obviously uh very damaging
are labor going to be the big Winners
out of this nobody's the winner at the
moment the cost of living that people
are going through Bill's going through
the roof Energy prices the situation
we've got internationally we've got
productivity low in this country people
need to see hope for their future not a
Psycho Drama constantly going on in
number 10 and around the government
we've had 13 years of Tory failure it's
now time to get labor in power who's got
a real plan on how we can really help
people's lives at the moment that's what
people want to see it's not a Psycho
Drama in Westminster they want to see us
doing the job at hand increasing
productivity in this country getting the
country back on track and investing in
our children's future and that's what
labor will do